[Musique]
il flottait un air de Noël avant l'heure
à la Commanderie depuis le début du mois
cette année encore le Noël est décalé
proposé un programme de fête pour ses
visiteurs le concept c'est de d'offrir
pendant 15 jours un certain nombre de
choses des activités des choses à faire
ou des choses à voir donc cette année et
aujourd'hui c'est le temps fort donc une
journée festive parmi les activités
phares le manège de Monsieur gaillard un
mélange d'attractions et de spectacles
qui a ravi les petits et les grands
[Musique]
manège met aussi balai aérien ou encore
atelier manuel des associations
solidaires et des créateurs étaient
également présents pour faire découvrir
l'artisanat local je travaille le Grey
et donc je façonne des pièces
utilitaires et fonctionnelles en grey je
fais tout à la main de A à Z donc
j'achète la terre sous forme de pain
d'argile et je la prépare je la tourne
je tourne sur un tour de potier et après
je fais la cuisson enfin les maillages
là il y a deux cuissons donc les
différentes cuissons voilà tout le
processus de fabrication en fait il fait
complètement artisanalement un
savoir-faire une précision qui se
retrouve dans ce vase jusqu'à sa
décoration en termes de décoration ce
que j'aime beaucoup c'est la
superposition de ces deux émo il y a
d'abord un noir en dessous on voit la
ligne de démarcation ici et un blanc par
dessus et ça fait toutes ces nuances
bleutées et vertes des stands très
apprécié par les visiteurs c'est des
boutiques à but humanitaires donc c'est
plutôt bien ça permet d'acheter un peu
plus responsable de quoi donner des
idées
elles heureux de faire des cadeaux
éthiques pour les fêtes